this is a familiar site in North kivu
people in sake west of Goma are fleeing
again from their homes they carry what
they can they say M23 Rebels are getting
closer to the town they've already taken
several Village centers and important
towns that are rich in minerals Janine
kiguma and her family have left their
home on the outskirts of sake they say
they are heading to a camp for displaced
people we came to sake from my Village
to see if sake was safe but all I could
hear were gunshots now I'm heading to
Goma we're tired of running
Congolese soldiers are doing what they
can to protect the areas but they have
often been forced Retreats as a Rebels
Advance Goma which is uh the provincial
capital of the largest city in the area
is now pretty much surrounded by the M23
Insurgent group Goma has Rwanda to one
side Lake kivu to the other and now the
North and the west and the roads that
Supply Goma with food and other Goods
which are principally from the north of
the province they're now effectively
controlled or at least strongly
contested by the M23 Regional leaders
from the East African Community have
been trying to mediate a peace deal but
it's proving increasingly difficult
Rwanda and the DRC have accused each
other of using armed groups in the
conflict both sides deny the allegations
during the recent African Union Summit
East Africa's Regional body iguard gave
M23 a month to withdraw from positions
they're holding it has been hard for the
leaders to enforce a ceasefire there is
at the moment I think little desire to
sanction the heads of the groups because
and in particular the M23 because the
intention is ultimately to bring them uh
to the negotiating table I think a
regional sanctioning of armed groups may
have some impact in sending uh signals
but it could only work if it was part of
continued diplomatic effort
after years of painful conflict few
Congolese are likely to be holding their
breath Catherine soy Al Jazeera